NONE OF US WANT THATEN.
GOKSREVENT THI FROM
THERE THINE.>>> PR
OVERTURN THE 2020 TIRATELY
VIOLENCE
SOHEGEORGIA -- HER
GA
STATE.ATAN
YOU  T SENEX
SOMEONIG OE GROUND
ARE POINO A WI
>>DON'T PUN THE SPOT THAT
MIROW ANCOMPLETELY UP TO THEM. E
I'M NN I'M HG OLI HAVE IT
MAY NO
W R
IN GEORG G A
MORE>> WEEKS
ONF N TOVERYBODY JUST HEARD
GEORGIA.
COMPLINGS AND COMING
E BALANCUE TEDURALER SIFRED OUY.
THE LI THOSE HAVTIL NOVEMBER.SO
THOUSAND VOTESY?
>> IT COULD, BUT THE GOOD NEWS
EARLY SO WE'RE DOWN TO ABOUT 70.
ON AN ADON 276
WE'RE GONNA BE HE  THE OREEMS T,
PROFESSIONALS
G INGED
OSTMARKED
BY TOR TCAACCEPTED.S NOT REALLYN
TIME YOU'LL SEE
CE
BE FRIDAY BUT
US
ND TYTY.
HA, AND I THINK
EVERYONE IADT TOAL
TURN.YOU'RE SAFE, AND I KNOU WEE
JUST SAYING AS GETTING
TOMORROW.RVIEW.
NO RAIN, 80 DEGREES, HOPEFULLYER
VOTING
THOUGH THIAR IN GEE EARLY VOTINE
MO
L
-- MATCH THE TURN
THIS IS A HUGELYCANTG TO ON ID H
WAS THE ST DAVE EARLKNR  PRESIDA
YEAR.
STUNNING.
WHAT DO YOU THIN DRIVEING THIS
WNK FOR TCOUPLE
GOVERN KEMP WI,000 VOTES AND PRT
11,000 IN 2020, I
THAN MOLE IN THE CORSTAND
THE WEIGHTEIR HAVING TVOTE.
IF YOU'RE VOTING FROM COLORADO
IFORNI
YOU'REARF PART SANSH
T IN GEORGIAR VOTETU
VERTURS 2020HONE CALL WHTHE FORD
ARRAISIN
TO THEY ARE.
>> WE'RE JUSTWO DAYSY FROM
THE STRM
N AMERICAN HISTORY.
WEA LANDSLIDE SO BIG
THAT T R RIT OSTEATHFRANCE IS II
>> WL,ODY.
>> OF COURSE THAT' ABSURD NOTOWT
TRP E
PELEERS COULD LEADO SOMEONEKILL.
RIGHT?
JANUARY 6th HAPPENED.
DO YOU FEEL A SENSOFA VU
AS WE' VG  IT'S UNFOR,
RY T GOES MORE THAN EIG
BALLOTS COMININATG N
THE COUNTRY
FOR THOSY D BALLOTS.
FRANKLY IHAD
PEOPLE WHO WERIDLO LOSE, I LOSE.
I COME BACK IN OR YEARS AND FIG0
AND I K WE'VE SEEN THAT FOR
THE MOARPEFUL
E'LL HAVE ONE OF THE
THINGS WE SAY  ENS IS, TURN- A D
BU'S VOTEREE